President Biden and other Democrats are
applauding a new report showing the
economy grew more than expected over the
summer now they hope that this is a sign
that we are not going into a recession
in spite of those Rising prices and
interest rates which is the key issue
for the voters Nancy Cortes is at the
White House was more on that story Nancy
good morning to you good morning Gail
here at the white house they made a big
deal about those GDP numbers they argued
it's another sign that the economy is
continuing to power forward but the
question is whether many Americans
really feel that Improvement in the face
of rising prices
great economic report today President
Biden hailed the GDP rebound Thursday a
healthy 2.6 annual Spike after two
straight quarters of decline although it
may not feel like for everyone people's
incomes went up last quarter more than
when inflation went up
but economists aren't applauding yet
they say high inflation and a decline in
consumer spending are warning signs of
what's to come we do think a recession
in 2023 is is more likely than not it
could start as early as as the first
quarter
the Federal Reserve has tried to drive
down prices by hiking interest rates but
groceries are still 13 percent more
expensive than last year and the fed's
moves have pushed mortgage rates to a
20-year High over seven percent for the
average 30-year fixed rate with 11 days
to go before the midterm elections
Republicans are hammering the president
on the economy every single thing they
touch turns to garbage
inflation out of control in Syracuse
President Biden argued the GOP has no
plan for the economy my Republican
friends in Congress seem to be hoping
for a recession many of them Majority
Leader Chuck Schumer was overheard
Thursday warning President Biden about a
critical battle in the Georgia Senate
race foreign
[Music]
during that tarmac conversation leader
Schumer also told President Biden that
it appears that the debate in
Pennsylvania didn't hurt the party that
much he was referring to the race
between Democrat John fetterman and
Republican Dr Mehmet Oz President Biden
and the Vice President are going to be
traveling to the Keystone State today to
hold a dinner supporting John fetterman
tonight Nate
there's a lot hanging in the balance
with midterm elections approaching Nancy
thank you